es una escena cotidiana en la Habana
filas desorganizadas frente a los
supermercados tensión cansancio porque
se pelean estos cubanos por la comida la
prioridad aquí es por orden de llegada
La Isla vive su peor crisis económica en
30 años
sin embargo estadounidense se vio
agravado por la pandemia y una
inoportuna reforma monetaria el peso se
desploma la escasez se agrada
siempre hambre lo cae en Cuba amanece
sobre la vieja Habana para Jesús Batista
profesor retirado la búsqueda de
alimentos se ha convertido en un trabajo
a tiempo completo buenos días Qué
producto va a vender
importa el 80% de sus necesidades la
crisis de Kobe 19 ha paralizado la isla
y las tiendas estatales están vacías
dice que van a dar 100 tickets nada más
hay más personas que turnos lo mismo
peor porque es la incertidumbre que hago
la cura cogeré no cogeré alcanzaré no
alcanzaré Después de tres horas la
funcionaria de la máscara amarilla
anunció que solo había 60 botellas de
aceite barato de las 100 prometidas una
desilusión para el pensionado y sus
compañeros de infortunio
y
y cuando no podemos y Cuando
llegaste
desde ayer desde ayer está aquí
ahí le pagan por hacer cola de los demás
un nuevo trabajo en el país de los
desposeídos
los Afortunados se van con su aceite
como tesoro en cuanto a Jesús vuelve a
su Modesto edificio con las manos vacías
y el ánimo Bajo como una gran parte de
los cubanos
entre los cortes de Electricidad y la
inflación galopante oficialmente el 70%
el año pasado el ambiente en la Habana
es sombrío
la capital es una sombra de lo que fue
sus emblemas más famosos están Incluso
amenazados como estos viejos coches
americanos Jorge está muy orgulloso de
su Chevrolet 56 ha pertenecido a su
familia durante varias generaciones pero
no sabe si podrá conservarlo durante
mucho tiempo
ante la pandemia misma dio a la tienda y
lo comprabas ahí fácilmente
y lo había pero ya
cada día se pone más difícil porque no
nos está entrando nada porque el
problema que es el turismo con el
problema la pandemia que ha bajado mucho
mi familia en las carreteras los cubanos
ya no prestan atención a las consignas
socialistas que recuerdan los ideales de
la revolución de 1959 ya casi nadie cree
en ellos cuando compran el mercado donde
los precios se disparan este informático
de 38 años se atreve a expresar el
sentimiento de muchos hijos y nietos de
la Revolución
no puedes hablar de igualdad cuando en
realidad Tú eres el primero que estás
creando la desigualdad Entonces ya eso
es un cuento eso pasó en desenchuche que
hay como decimos los cubanos que entre
una generación y la otra que no es para
nada las mismas experiencias no
conocemos otra cosa que todos los días
lo mismo la comida la comida la comida
bajo presión el gobierno ha acelerado
las reformas económicas desde 2021 se
permiten pequeñas empresas privadas en
casi todos los sectores para este joven
empresario Esta es la forma de salir de
la crisis junto con los 20 empleados de
su pequeña empresa de electricidad
trabajan en obras de construcción en la
Habana la mejor manera de de poder
ofrecerle a estos jóvenes un trabajo que
que les llame la atención es de esta
manera es que una empresa tenga la
libertad que sin duda alguna son mucho
en muchos casos mucho más llamativos que
las empresas verás soluciones que le
pueden dar en el sector estatal en la
isla socialista el espíritu empresarial
se desarrolla como consecuencia de la
crisis